to
the project governance group meeting
uh as you'll be aware the chair
is in isolation so uh
it's asked me to cheer again on behalf
of the project governance group can i
firstly just
assure everybody that
we as
live streaming and also welcome the
media which
in attendance for the meeting
are there any apologies
there being none is there a notification
for reasonable general business
nothing to report under health and
safety michael
yeah
can we turn to the man just back just
back to the general business and urgent
business
um i will move a motion
that the latter part of our meeting
which is in public excluded be brought
back into uh into public
thank you
councillor
um we'll note that and we'll do so
following um
the
notification of the stuff that's on the
publicly we were on the publicly exclude
we'll have a discussion about that mr
chair the process would be that at the
time you called for a motion to move and
public excluded
you could have a debate on it a motion
to bring it forward is not required
thank you so we're happy we'll do it
that way
yes sorry mr chair i'm just looking for
richard hardy because i was speaking to
him last night and expecting him to be
here i'm surprised that he's not on zoom
yet
we'll
see that if he joins us uh can we then
move to the minutes from the previous
meeting
are there any additions or alterations
to the minutes
as the draft form
everybody happy would somebody like to
move them as a true and correct record
thank you again chair just just as a
point of clarification for the last
meeting
at the last meeting i gave an
undertaking
for some action that would lead into
this meeting and i just need to clarify
that
i've been asked by some of my colleagues
at the chairs meeting yesterday to
clarify this position
so at the um
once we've done the approval of the
meetings we'll do it under the actions
and
okay are you happy to do it then
yep fine thank you
so we've got to move that
council scout seconded by councillor
soper all those in favor
all right
so manners are rising
robbie can you um yeah thank you chair
um at the end of the last meeting i gave
an undertaking that i would contact the
mayor and his partner
um and so these uh the dates and the
actions that i've taken
to afford the mayor an opportunity to
either give us feedback on the legacy
report at a meeting or alternatively
independent of the meeting where you can
do it privately so on the 23rd of april
i
had contact with
the mayor and his partner by way of a
telephone call and during that they
asked me about the legacy report which
was
which was pending i advised them
that it was available on board books and
that it would be discussed at the
following wednesday meeting which was
the 26th
and that was a close workshop
at that workshop on the 26th the mayor
was absent he was a late apology
and did not attend and did not submit
any uh written
thoughts on what he
wanted to present in relation to the
legacy report
and then post that meeting on the 26th i
gave another taking that i'd make
further contact with me and his partner
which i did i emailed the mayor and i
also rang his partner as well
to advise
that
we would extend a further period from
the 26th quickly sunday the 1st of may
to allow the mayor to give feedback as
we valued his opinion and felt it was
important that he contributed um the
mayor has not elected to do any feedback
on that report so it now sits
uh songs in that area i think that's
important because some of my colleagues
are asking
um have we afforded enough time
or an appropriate opportunity for the
mayor to contribute and i do now believe
we have thank you
thank you councillor look guys
that's my understanding was that
the reason for the legacy report to be
been publicly excluded initially was on
that basis to give everybody an
opportunity to
to provide feedback and that has taken
place okay
can we move to the project secretariat
update
jane
thank you jeff luke just briefly
i guess there's three purposes to this
meeting there's three things we'll be
asking clear direction on um they're all
in bullet points there
but the key thing is probably the legacy
report itself and whether the pgg
are happy to recommend to counsel that
they adopt it and when we discuss it we
we're open to
any amendments that
the group
may have today but
it would be fair to say we feel it's
been through due process
and we think that
we've put every best effort to
put together a report
that tells it like it is so
we will um
council will debate that um
but the the pgg will get to that one
the second thing um
that the pgg would
be asking council to do
is
send the report to the dia
and finally
we would be
suggesting that the monitoring functions
continue
with risk and assurance so i think
that's that's the overall big picture of
what we want to discuss today we can go
into more detail
but mr you might want to
go to item 2 which was the issue on the
ph session having had that there's a
motion coming to take it in public
thanks very much jane can we um
just
go through the rest of the report and
then we'll come back to the legacy in
terms of publicly excluded
radio
um so in section three
the bullet points are all
self-explanatory
maybe if i focus on the second last one
um
because of the the time frames we need
to write a covering report
for council on your behalf and the six
things there
that i
believe we need to
cover in that report and the last bullet
point suggests given the tight time
frames because this will need to go
online on i think it's thursday day
after tomorrow
that
the chair and the chief executive sign
off this report on your behalf
the next section uh do you want to pause
for any comments or i'll just keep going
shall i
uh look just just in that section under
six
i just um from a discussion that
both lindsay and i have had would there
be some consideration that the role of
the ea's
tenure finished on the 31st of may
following the report being
approved by council rather than 30th of
june
um
the comment is
i don't really see the need to hang
around for another month
your confidence is appreciated mr chair
um bruce looks like he's going to make a
comment he might do that
sorry no i just look jeff i i agree and
with your optimism and i think and it is
an affirmation um jane i'm you know from
my perspective uh senior bassman but i
would be comfortable if deaf and lindsey
were released on the 31st of may
um um that's on the assumption i think
that the report is we've got it drafted
more or less goes through and is
accepted by council that's great i would
have thought if the council was
approving all the other aspects of the
report
uh it would seem to me to be just a
logical conclusion
[Music]
and cancels its hands i'm going back to
um
the early days
when we said we'd take this through
until the end of june
and reflecting back and
as we've moved through this year there's
a what i'm observing to be a very nice
gradual
wind down
um
however having said that
i don't sit in invercargill
and
it's up to the council laws themselves
thanks uh lindsay i'm the institute
yeah look thanks uh chair and
um colleagues i'd support our early exit
um there are a number of reasons for
that
and it is contingent on the report going
through
with dia endorsement on the 24th one of
the reasons that i favor it is that we
already are seeing candidacies announced
for office around the council table and
i am concerned that the further on we go
with time
the more drawn in despite our best
efforts we will be into that um
pre-election
um
interchange and i think we should avoid
that because that was um something that
i think thompson among others said that
we should be alert to
thanks uh sir tim
so tim did you
yes i just wanted to give notice that
i'll be opposing
the um
progress on this matter it's got to go
still before council great
so tim we'll we'll we'll deal with that
when we get to dealing with the legacy
report
councillor sopa
thank you mr chair i was just going to
say that um
i would agree with the external advisors
that
if if your assessment is that the 31st
of may is an appropriate time
and we have been very grateful for your
role as external advisors
but as you say i see no reason to
prolong
for another month
what is indicated as some
the end of a very intensive exercise
where you've
contributed a great deal and as you've
indicated as lindsay has indicated
there is a move into a different part of
the council cycle it would be a sensible
date i think for the 31st of may
obviously with the proviso that the
legacy report has accepted but
i'm confident that we're at that
maturity point
thank you
so are there any other comments in
regards to that can we oh sorry
knobby
you gotta hand it yeah just to reinforce
what others are saying um i don't see as
chair that where there's any benefit
going forward i think the biggest risk
is the one that lindsey's raised that we
have candidates now lining up to be mere
and that's part of a normal cycle
and i think it's important for
ratepayers to be able to see how those
candidates and others behave leading up
to the election without having
the eas who have been referred to at
times as trainer wheels um
supporting the organisation it's time
for us to sort of stand up and we know
what needs to be done and how it needs
to be done and those who want to have a
future on the council should also be
mindful of that
so i'd be quite happy for the earlier
exam
thank you
for the record chair i'm also in
agreement of that
cheers thank you council lewis
scalp
number four was the legacy report
workshop which is just effectively
telling us the process in terms of that
sorry
um richard
i'm not thank you first of all apologies
for my lateness um but i'm here so
that's all good and um apologies for
missing the first part of the discussion
but i just wanted to one other thing we
do need to consider um
uh the elections really good point the
upcoming elections and and making sure
we steer clear of that but if the um
if the eas are going to end early we
need to think very carefully about just
the media lines and getting um the right
sort of statements out there as to
what is driving this and and
what it looks like moving forward just
something to keep on our radar thank you
richard
councillor
thank you mr chair um just on on number
four i just wanted to comment on on
paragraph three there
um
i think perhaps it doesn't quite capture
the discussion which was
the i think the disappointment was that
because one councillor hadn't completed
the report
um there
there could be a suspicion in the
public's mind that it was any counsellor
there there was no identification so i'm
not sure that it was any disappointment
that
those of us who had filled out the
report were being acknowledged i think
it was more that
there could be a suspicion that any of
us had been that one person and and that
was unfortunate so it was really
expressed in that way it was unfortunate
that one councillor had chosen
to
to to decide on something that was not
entirely collegial on this matter
it wasn't that any of us were seeking
acknowledgement for having done it
in fairness most surveys never get more
than 40 so i thought it was pretty good
outcome really
um
five
jane
five is a bit long and involved um
there's uh
the updates as i've said are shown in
red and quite a few things can be ticked
off
given the that we've got the legacy
report done
important to note that the resident
survey
will be
continuing we're recommending it
continues on
but part of the
concluding work of this group is that
this
reporting table gets a tidy up and goes
to risk and assurance and i think that's
really important so that we keep the
momentum going
so unless there's particular questions
about anything
um
i think it stands for itself
any questions in regard to the updated
version which will note and read any
changes
and the pgg agreed to the recommendation
that they would now go to the auditor
risk
yep
and then the budget update nothing
further to progress we're still on
target as projected to come under budget
the risks um we've had a really good
look at this table this time and closed
off the majority of the risks
there's four
left there
and section seven it tells you what they
are and again
they should become no it should be
incorporated into the council's
risk register
rather than the organization's risk
register and
important to keep that
top of mind too
any questions on that one
there appear to be none jane
okay um lisa's written the comms update
i think she's there i don't know if
there's anything she wants to add lisa
pieces here and
um nothing much to add really it's been
very quiet as you can see there and
you've probably been following along um
it does outdate very quickly this update
though so
there's always new things popping up
number nine
number nine is where we started
so that's suggesting that we need to
or the governance group
needs to formalize a report to council
hopefully supporting
being happy to support the final legacy
report
the next two are later to and from the
dia
number four
um
the
pgg
has done its job
number five is the consequential
monitoring rule which we've talked about
already in number six i've got the
change date loud and clear thank you
cheers thank you any questions in terms
of the six
bullet points under project closure
okay on that basis chair you need to
have those eyes on the side of your head
again
i've got a screen in front of me too now
and you know it's a bit of a worry um
just just on the comment that jane made
and regard to pg having done its job
um
um
i guess uh a warning for all of us
around the table and those who are not
present as the
the report that we've got now the impact
survey report
um
does have some concerns within it
and i'm not attempting to troll through
that but it does have um some areas of
concern and it does have some areas
where we've got slippage between the um
the previous impact report that was done
and this current one so i guess just
alerting members of
the peg and it's uh activity over
quite a lengthy period now has not been
a silver bullet that's solved everything
we still have some momentum to maintain
um
and given the period that we're coming
up to now pre-election um that will be a
challenge in its own right
no did i look i think one of the other
slight differences in terms of the
impact report was that the impact report
last time did include senior staff and
the eas this one only include
counsellors i thought the councils are
all slightly harsher on themselves this
time around but um
i i think that
does slightly reflect in the report
uh this time around is on the basis that
it was actually only counsellors
uh there any other items under the
public
piece can we now move to
cliff sorry jeff i'm trying to
make a quick comment please yes sorry
bruce yes no worries i didn't get my
hand up in time um
first you just want to acknowledge that
um i agree with the proposal this comes
to the risk insurance committee um but i
hear your point jane that it needs to be
followed through with some seriousness
we do have one meeting between now and
50 june and i'm just conscious
in terms of thinking about the disaster
of the pgg which i broadly support that
there will only be one meeting in the
rna between now and 30 june and some of
the outcome measures jane
require action in june um it probably
isn't
a great moment we will meet again
later in the year which i presume is not
a bad time to be able to
check that all the measures that are
anticipated the internal audit work have
been completed from the outcome
perspective all i'm trying to reflect
here is that is that the rna doesn't
meet as regularly as the pgg has
um and just to reflect that in terms of
the resolution to disestablish the pgg
now
thank you
good point bruce but i do do assume that
the section will continue its good work
in between now and the next rna meeting
and so that those matters will still be
attended to uh prior to the next rna
mode in this case
uh look um
there's nothing else under the public
can we move to what is currently the
publicly excluded part of the agenda for
the project governance group
and
uh
intention was to move a publicly
excluded session but um
has already been discussed it was
intended that we
move out of publicly excluded for the
review of the legacy report
councillor clark
yes i'd like to move on notion that we
remain an open
um and the rationale for that is that
everybody
internally
needs to have some input into the
uh draft legacy report that we're now
reviewing has had their opportunity
i think there's two
pieces of work around this this
reporting it's the legacy report itself
which is a an overarching report but
important inside that is the impact
survey governance research report that
we've now got an open one in fact the
the latter of those two reports is the
one that's the most detailed because as
you quite rightly said it focuses on
it on on the feedback directly from
elected members and nobody else and so
and we're a bit harsher on ourselves so
i think it's um
if anything you could have argued the
other way around
and i think it's important that this now
be out on the table
so the public can have a view of the
work and and
the results that we've achieved so
my preference would be to have that and
i'll i'll move accordingly i'll second
that second by councillor sopra uh any
comments or questions
i've got
sorry yeah bruce
yeah look i'd um i
am
probably the view
uh nobody that i don't quite agree with
your view
um i think in terms of process here
the the key is so i'm getting feedback
are you [ __ ] having trouble hearing
this
that's
sorry mr chair if councillor clark could
put his system on mute
i think you'll find that noise goes
thank you
all right thank you look all i'm wanting
to reflect here without prolonging
debate is
um i see this as uh the process we
followed through through the workshop is
enabling all of council to have
uh uh to have a look at the report and
comment
and i think really the role as has been
intended in the agenda is for
pgg to do its work and i think it should
be in px so that it can release two
through normal intended public process
which is going to occur next week uh the
consideration by the whole council
because it's a report on the whole
council on themselves
in public so
i would actually suggest that that even
though i don't suspect what i'm hearing
there's going to be a lot of debate over
the report this morning that it be in px
but actually that it then be released
publicly
because it's going to go out on thursday
anyway
for full consideration by council
because actually in the long run the
critical thing here is that council is
happy with the report and they should
have that chance
to do it without it being done by us
publicly here
sir tim
yes i i do
um
i think it should be held and open even
though it'll be
basically a
celebrity roast of the mayor
um i'm getting used to that by now
but um
the
i think going in um
we should always try to be as
open as possible and transparent as
possible
and
note it's a tim i'll be speaking again
thank you sir uh sorry council clark do
you hand up
yeah thank you um just in response to
bruce's
abuse and and we normally agree on
everything but not this one i'm afraid
um
as a as a
democratic process and trying to allow
members elected members to have uh
suitable access prior to public release
it was my recall that we had a fairly
high level of attendance at the workshop
we had which was
in public excluded
we went over the legacy report
nothing significantly changed in the
legacy report other than the fact
that the
impact survey governance report is now
on the table and i don't understand why
we have yet another meeting
one of the issues that concerns me is
that if we go to a meeting on the 10th
of may and it's released then
i suspect the media will want to have
some
some ability to report on what happens
at that final meeting and when you read
the full legacy report including the
impact survey
governance research report it is a very
very lengthy document
it goes historically back over a lot of
stuff and i'm not sure whether we want
that to occur it would be nice for them
just to look at the more recent stuff to
show where we're at now as opposed to
going back to the
original reports we have that
were triggered after the dia so i guess
i'm still in favor of having this in the
open and give the media about a week to
troll through the report and see what
they
see in them
much further uh knobby not because i
want to agree with you necessarily um i
just think in terms of process it is for
council as a whole you consider the full
report but i'm recommending it actually
we release it after we have done our
consideration today just in case there's
any particular matter that needs to be
changed by either me and more
particularly jane
then can be released it's going to be
public as i understand it anyway by
thursday um so that both council and
dean the media and the public have the
chance to have a full consideration of
it uh before tuesday the 10th so um it's
really just about around process but i'm
not just going to unduly uphold the
motion
if it's a view of the committee that we
should do this in public now
cheers thanks bruce is there any further
discussion
yes sir thank you mr chair
um
i feel that
[Music]
we've got to shoot this issue back to
the thompson report
and
the issues that were raised there
were always the support for the
mayor and
the report doesn't address this issue i
mean why are there no questions such as
do you think the mayor has sufficient
admin support
and
uh
have you witnessed any
activities that show support for the
mayor
have you talked to the mayor about
any issues he has raised
and
i can understand why councillors refused
to take part
or one councillor refused to take part
in the survey
because of privacy concerns
and when that survey was done we were
promised that
it would be confidential
that doesn't seem to have happened
either
well firstly yeah so tim the the
so that we don't run into out of context
in terms of the discussion the
discussions as is really about whether
the legacy report should be publicly
excluded or not at this part of the
process i think there's a overwhelming
uh support noting uh the words of um
the chair of the audit committee um for
to be publicly released at this stage i
think that's the matter that we're
discussing now then discuss the legacy
report um post that decision
uh council asoka
thank you mr chair look as the seconder
of the motion i was and as someone who's
very interested in process
um it it just seems to me that it's
entirely sensible at this
stage to
um
bring it into public there is really
in the reasoning for which we put things
into public excluded i think we are at
the point where we where we don't have
the argument any longer to to
justifiably say
section 481
a applies here and i think it is
entirely sensible that it comes into the
public and um and that we have that
discussion now so so i think it's a moot
point we could
as um as the chair of audit suggests we
could do it the other way but i think um
i think it's part of the maturity
um point which we have reached in this
exercise that it is time that this is
public
thank you very much and before the
legacy report becomes bigger than being
her um
we have a mission on the table uh moved
by councillor clark and signing by
councillor sopa
all those in favor of the motion
chair just like to make a further
comment that's the
lever of the motion one more
yes i understand the one more yes um
given that where this is um
an open meeting live stream i cannot
allow the mayor's comments to go
unchallenged it puts an inappropriate
context into this work that we've done
so i just want to clarify two things he
raised the issue of
one of his colleagues not completing the
survey and that was clearly not his
worship his worship
did the survey
but i can categorically hand on heart
say that
the um
the impact survey governance research
report has been totally confidential
i've been at odds at times to sort of a
little bit name and shame the counselor
didn't complete the survey and the
feedback i've been have is it was a
confidential survey and there would be
no further disclosure
so i just wanted the public to know that
and the other issues that the mayor
raised was with a
series of issues that he raised and i
don't want to litigate through those i
just want to make the statement that
certainly as deputy mayor i've
given a lot of time and effort in the
last
year and a half
to try to resolve the issues that the
mia has raised around bullying around
budget control around pa hours around
cell phones and i.t
on on each occasion the mayor has
defaulted from the support that was
offered to him
thank you thank you councillor clark so
informational tour and everybody's
agreed all right
goes against
all right
so tim that was the motion to put it
into public
which i think you were supporting
earlier in the meeting
so sir tim you against putting the
legacy report into public
so tim
would note then that tim
has now chosen to not approve the
report going into public because that
corrects it him
thank you so on that basis
majority have supported the report to go
into
public so we will now move to
the legacy report
and look
has been commented before this report
has gone through an
extensive process including the workshop
we've had a number of attempts to get it
tidy and i firstly just want to note
uh both jane and bruce for the work that
you have done
jane especially with the
tireless job of putting the pen to it
and on that basis i'm proposing that we
go back page by page
and there's
the intention of the report was really
brought about on the basis of saying
is a conclusion to the work that's been
done especially through the
working groups in terms of the
committees over a long period of time
across a whole range of topics
that we should write a report that just
concludes the process
and also in terms of the ability for the
council to work through
a whole range of things that were raised
originally in the thompson report and i
think that the report itself does
reflect that so on that basis
uh if you're happy we'll move to the
report itself on a page by page basis
jane you're happy to do it that way
absolutely thank you
radio
so
we'll skip to the first one which is
contents and purpose page so i'm going
off um
off the board books
diligent boards are on page five purpose
one
there any comments in regard to that
page
page six
page seven
page eight
page nine under scene setting
[Music]
10
11 it's quite hard to watch just those
in the room and zoom at the same time
but
if you put your hand up i'll give it a
catcher
it's an 11 that's simply a male thing
12.
really
absolutely 13 under fixing the problem
14
15
16
page 17
[Music]
18
19
20
21
22. yeah just to backtrack i missed
something there sorry bear with me
um i was going slowly
not for me
um
i thought you passed my report
[Laughter]
i think when i was back on pages 16 and
17 jeepers
okay council [ __ ] 16
yep
um
i think this was something discussed at
the last meeting about
um
um
given this legacy document may be of
interest to dia and to other councils
that are working potentially through
some of the problems
about
um
and that's probably not to be a result
here but just a flag i guess that
um
i gave feedback to bruce wood and jane
when they did the interviews that i felt
the last 18 months was a very lonely
place for me as deputy mayor
i sort of caught between um
tiptoeing around what i could
realistically do as a deputy mayor
uh in night of the mental situation
but then um not wanting to um
go over the top of what my counselors
might see as the appropriate role as
well
um and where would the boundaries be on
that and so the report doesn't disclose
what could have happened in an ideal
world
and i guess for a legacy document going
forward that's just a gap i think in the
reporting i'm not trying to add in the
end of the state just probably signaling
for richard's benefit
um
that that's still an area of you know
how could we have done that a little bit
better
yeah wasn't it i wasn't quite a lonely
place for a long time yeah look council
crack i think perfection is always a
really hard thing to write
sure in terms of the report i i do i
i see where you're coming from but i do
think that
um
the report does reflect and especially
around this area um
that
you know these things are not simple
when it's not a straight road
it does have
some zigzags in it and
look like
i think we understand from the
perspective of the last 18 months that's
so close
right
21 22
23
24
25 which starts the learnings
26
oh sorry lindsay
yeah just uh timings um perfection chair
uh just on page 26 gives me the
opportunity to say two things
firstly to the authors
to congratulate them on the way in which
they've picked up the feedback from the
workshops
and secondly just to acknowledge
the way in which you have recorded the
contribution that jeff and i have made
to the work stream
we both would like
to just recognize the
appropriateness i guess of the way
you've reflected our input
and recorded and
recorded it in the legacy report
all right thanks lindsay
26
27
28 which starts what could have been
done better yeah that that's my area
jeff
i've got a bit ahead of myself that was
the area that i thought
from a legacy perspective
um
it could have been more comics yeah look
i'd i think the headings probably the
appropriate one and 10.2 what could have
been done better um
yep and that's okay i'm okay with the
report yeah like it is 29.
i just i just want to comment because i
had um marked the learnings yeah um
just just to say
um i think this is a really important
part of the document um and on
since you've announced page 29 i'll just
point out the further learning
opportunities paragraph and
on 29
does imply that this could be taken
further
with the dia
to um to progress
the learnings and and what could um
result
that might assist other councils in the
future
or indeed this council in some far
future
so i think to that extent councillor
clark i think what you've referred to
has been captured there and that there
can be
further discussion and progress on that
particular learnings aspect
well council so we had quite a
discussion around this aspect at the
last ptg you know it is great i think
that we really came back to the point at
the end of the day this report was what
icc did yeah
it is the intention that it allows for
other councils to
to probably reflect if they are in a
similar position
uh as to process but we then came back
to a conclusion that it was really for
the dia
to take up if there was a view within
the department that there is a much more
extensive
writing that could be done in terms of
process and things that may
because each council would be slightly
different and i think we came to the
view rightly so that this is really
foreign city council sign off not um
not
in a
pendium that was telling other councils
how they should do it
uh 2930
we had quite a discussion also on this
one i think we landed in the right place
in terms of
additional uh
appendixes to the report and is i think
quite rightly noted the others are
available on the website
um icc website without loading a whole
range of them
as there are a number of dirty m's
there that we won't need to discuss are
there any other questions or comments in
regards to the legacy report itself
um jeff could i just um without wanting
to have andrew focus on my report it has
changed a wee bit since um the last
meeting given the comments i received
could you just do a very short page turn
on addendum 4.
yep i'm sorry
get to a bruise it's quite a bit to get
you sorry mate i don't know i'm really
getting really focused but i just
reflect the uh counselors that i think
the pgg should have a chance just to
make any comment
uh given that it is the other one that
has moved a wee bit since the council
workshop not significantly it's just
really for coming but i just i'd like to
have it no there's no more changes
needed
all right so if we could somebody got a
number
uh 86 of 91.
oh no
so the wrap up review um
as bruce has pointed out was also
discussed at the workshop but there have
been a couple of additions since that
point priests from the workshop yeah
primary she primarily calling it a
review
here i say it rather than comments um
look it has changed a wee bit not not
not significantly
the probably the primary feedback back i
had was on page 87 which was around the
reasonable description
um of
the how the chairs group had existed
prior to
either working on working together
but i have used the word it's
reconfigured the way it's work which was
the permanent inclusion of claire as a
member or as an attendee i'm not quite
certain how you call it clear
in the quick circulation of the notes
that was the critical thing um the other
thing that um has done and it's not
inconsistent well um i i don't know
whether it's the same but it's not
inconsistent with also the fact that
i've noted that we had one
non-participant in the in the reviews at
that stage that person wasn't disposed
through health reasons so um
uh
[Music]
um i just wanted to note that they were
probably the two key changes that i've
made so i just pointed out
thank you
any questions in regards to the comments
from bruce
there being none
uh it's my intention
that we
approve the report of the
oh sorry yeah this might be really
nitpicky but um in case you're
overlooked page 53 of board books
a um there's a the wrong use of the word
two
it has um and
paragraph 52
uh the fourth to the bottom line of that
but seen by the individuals i talked to
t double o i think it should be t o
better it was for that
that might be
transcribed somewhere along the line i
think that's an appendix isn't it
yeah it's the real problem for richard i
think i think it is yeah that goes back
to thompson we haven't they might have
been transcribed
we'll tell them when we send them a copy
of the
final legacy report
finally after 18 months we picked up mr
thompson
well an actual input
input report also
which is still in this part of the
agenda since we transferred page 24
oh
page 7 of the impact report i believe uh
there's an extra r at the end of the
sentence
thank you
well debit there are fees
yes
well done
thank you
uh
so are there any other comments
would somebody like to move that pgg
accept the legacy report and the just
one other thing here i mean sorry um
frequently
during these reports we we mentioned the
charter i know you just mentioned that
there are other reports that we haven't
included
expediency perhaps the charter i believe
was a very important part of our process
and i wonder that the charter should be
quoted verbatim as a report
um
look a good question uh it
the chat has played quite a critical
part in my view over the last 18 months
since the council signed off
the question really is should it be
formally here
rather than on the website
any thoughts
chain will be pleased to have one more
um yeah i've got some news on that chair
um
we had some discussion about um this
issue and others at the last meeting
um i guess one of the issues that we
have is that the
uh the charter in its own right is fine
but it does lead on to further debates
which we may not want to be drawn into
or to cloud this report and and the
debate around that is we've got some
members liquor members who feel that
there's a systemic problem within local
government per se
around how you um
how you lodge
code of conduct complaints for people
that are outside the charter in their
behaviour
and i'm not sure that we'd want to
extend
the discussion
into that area uh certainly at election
time
so council crack i think though
absolutely right there's a quite a
broader debate that came from the work
in terms of
the the issue of
code contact code of conduct processes
etc and i think the chart has played an
important part
in dealing with that and the council in
the way they operate now
uh
really council lewis is just raising the
question as should it be in
as an appendix to the report rather than
on the website
wrong part
so the question is
does the committee agree
that we should add one more appendix
which would be the charter rather than
having it on the website
uh mr chair at the lengthy
at the lengthy list of appendices that
we decided weren't appropriate this is
probably the one yeah
that there is actually an argument it
would be sensible i think as council
lewis says to put in
the the other parts of the long list we
agreed there on the website um but this
one yes was
integral to the process and
yes
should be the one that's added
so we've got a proposal that we do add
one more appendix which is the council
charter is there any objection to that
there appears to be none and so we'll do
that with a min to the
motion that we add one appendix
thank you counselor so if there's
somebody like this oh checking that
taken by councillor lewis uh all those
in favor of the legacy report being
accepted and sent to council please say
aye aye those against
carried
so we should note that it was carried
unanimously i would sure appreciate from
the committee's perspective
uh and on that basis thank everybody
that has been involved
um
i think it's been a good process in
terms of
for the council as as part of the sign
up but i also think
it is useful in reply to the original
letter from dia that
that the council has chosen to formally
respond
at the end of the process
are there any other matters
yeah the chair just uh as chair pg and
an original member well it's just it's a
big question it's like to reflect uh and
reinforce what you've just said um and a
particular thing bruce and jane up for
their work in the background and
sometimes not in the background
i think if jane hadn't kept up with the
uh
the format that she constantly used
which was a thorn on our side at times
going back over and over and over those
bloody things
um
i think we will easily have been
sidetracked off under areas that we
didn't need to be in and we would have
lost sight of some things that we
subsequently now realize are quite
important so
just like to thank you both for the work
you've done
thanks very much
and uh we
from a committee perspective
pose that and
on that basis unless there anything
under general i will intend to close the
meeting and thank you for your time
cheers thank you guys that have zoomed
in we'll catch you later
you